[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm kitty HD here and
if you remember way back in the earliest
days of Android we had on phones like
the g1 and the Nexus one we had just the
Google voice assistant then 2011 we were
introduced to our little friend on
iPhones called Siri and on both phones
its advanced so on Android phones now
we've gone to having Google now where
you have all these predictive cards
information and then now we've gone to
the point where we have Google assistant
and on iPhones it's still advanced as
well with software updates but she's
still called Siri so the question is
where we are with these things so this
is the Battle of the personal assistants
in your phone this is Google pixel XL
vs. iPhone 7 plus the latest and
greatest this is Android 7.1 versus iOS
1003 this is Google assistant vs. Siri I
kind of feel like I already know how
this one's going to go but let's just do
it anyway alright so here we go what's
the weather ok here's the weather Arnie
it's 70 in cloudy there will be showers
today with a forecasted high of 71 in a
low of 65 so it's pretty simple moving
on what's 20 times 15 minus 8 the answer
is 292 now that math open Instagram so
you can see they both have the ability
to open any app on your phone by name
set a timer for two minutes there Tyler
two minutes and Counting starting so
there you go you can see the Siri one is
like a split second ahead woke me up at
7:30 tomorrow morning all right you're
al are set for 2:30 maybe let's not do
that
remind me to water the lawn when I get
home ok how do you want to change the
arrived at home yes ok reminder saved so
geolocation tasks work really well
especially when both know where your
home is
when is the post office close I found
Cherie business hours for the post
office have the one you are looking for
u.s. post office on West Side Avenue
Jersey City is open today from 8:30 a.m.
to 4:00 p.m.
what's Tesla's stock price Kurtis
Kessler's discovery it's rated $200
today cents a share seven okay so this
one you can see Google's she's giving me
this price and a delta which is all I
asked for
but series actually giving me this
little graph form Yahoo Finance who is
the President of the United States
looking the president of the United
States of America is Barack Obama okay I
found this on the web for who is the
President of the United States okay so
sometimes when Syria doesn't know
something it just googles it or bangs it
or just searches the web and gives you
that instead how tall is he he's 6 feet
1 inch tall someone just asked me this
the other day give me a sec here's what
I found on the web for how tall is
United States awesome yeah that's great
how tall yeah so Google as you can see
is more conversational this is a big pro
of it is that it can use context clues
to talk about what you were previously
talking about where Siri might not
remember but if you just ask straight up
they can both tell you so how tall is
Barack Obama let's see six feet one
notch Obama is 6 feet 0.8 inches tall so
you can see if you just reavoice the
question Siri can give you the full
answer who won the Super Bowl the Super
Dome answers were the driving pros in
the Super Bowl on February 7th 2016 the
final score was 24 to 10 that time again
Siri gave me more than I asked for
Google just said the Broncos won but
Siri gave me the date the score who won
and a box score who's the quarterback
Trevor I can't answer that
Paxton Lynch and others are quarterbacks
for the Denver Broncos so same thing as
last time if you just ask who's the
quarterback Siri doesn't know but you'd
have to ask who's the quarterback of the
Denver Broncos did the Clippers win the
final score was 106 to 103 play this is
kind of funny because on the left you're
actually getting preseason games that
Clippers just played the kings in the
preseason so Yahoo Sports is really good
but Google's still telling me the last
regular-season game we played which was
losing to the Trailblazers in the
playoffs last season what song is this
here's an answer Felicity because that
failed on Google assistant but the funny
part is if I actually go to Google now
and ask what song is this actually works
don't you like for sweatpants by
Childish Gambino seems like assistant is
just a little half-baked you're
listening to IV sweatpants by Childish
Gambino what is a mitochondria here's
some medication an organelle found in
large numbers in most cells in which the
biochemical processes of raspberry right
yet it's the powerhouse of the cell
Google likes to talk a lot what is the
capital of Nepal Khan mondo is the cab
mildew is the capital of Nepal okay what
time is it there in durbar marginal the
time Katmandu Nepal is 27 a.m. on Friday
so far so good
what is the population the population
count do Emilio are you really any 11
okay so Syriac Chua li was
conversational that time but for some
reason we got different numbers from
Google or Siri depends on you trust who
is Mark Zuckerberg according to
Wikipedia mark Elias Zuckerberg is an
American well Grammer is internet
entrepreneur executive and
philanthropist okay I don't know if it's
just because it's by Apple but multiple
times I've tried this it's asked me who
is Mark Zuckerberg
I think that's hilarious who is Mark
Zuckerberg here's some information there
we go
let's trust more conversation how old is
he mark 7 32 years old and then who is
his wife Priscilla Jim says 22 other
wife of Mark Zuckerberg is Priscilla
Chan so Google read at that time how
tall is she
she's five feet five inches tall and
anything on how tallest series tapping
out on this one
when does guardians of the galaxy to
come out which one
guardians of the galaxy vol T
re-released Allegheny Valley of America
on lead with twenty seven thousand
seventeen what about Tim what's the
rating I don't know it really is at the
galaxy vol T so this is another one both
assistants don't really know so Google's
just going to give me a Google web
search pretty classic so he's just gonna
tell me more things that she knows show
me pictures of German shepherds here are
some images of German shepherds I found
on the web so I'm not sure what happened
at Google there but yes I'm getting some
pictures of German Shepherds via Bing on
Siri show me pictures of cats this is
fun you can actually get pictures that
I've taken of cats from my google photos
in the search assistant well again I'm
getting a Bing search on the iPhone but
if I just want to search the web again
with the Google assistant I can of
course do that show my photos from
yesterday this is what I found in your
google photos there you go that's all
the photos I've taken with each camera
in the last like 24 hours but if we
really want to get conversational we can
do something like I don't know how are
you today
I'm doing great mark thanks for asking
anything I can help with what's going on
just checking out see what I can find
can tell your scores if here's what's
trending on Twitter okay so if I ask
what's going on Siri will tell me what's
trending on Twitter most of which looks
like it's not English and the Google's
going to give me a bunch of like search
suggestions for other things I can
search for that are going on so that's
cool hey yeah
make me a sandwich with food you're a
sandwich
oh my Gap tell me a joke Marcus I don't
really know eating a Monster eats after
he's had his teeth checked the dentist
oh my god it's brutal I need a good pun
here's what I'll either so straight a
good pun they have to go by the book
she's kind of used to be serious Forte
of being like funny and being like a
thing to talk to you while Google is
more robotic
now I'm getting web search results from
Syrian Google seems to be excelling at
just talking what do you think of Siri
she has a lovely name what do you think
of Google I think therefore I am
but let's not put the cart before the
horse oh now you come with the joke all
right so long story short there are two
main things that I've learned and that
I've noticed from on my testing I've
been using these both of these
assistants on and off for the better
part of the last couple years but this
is what I've noticed one as far as
talking goes Google tends to read out
the answer a lot more wal Siri will just
say here you go and then display the
information often a little bit more
beautifully but I feel like when I'm
using the voice assistant when I'm
talking it's because I can't like go to
my phone and use it or look at it maybe
I'm driving maybe I'm away from it so I
kind of like when it reads it out more
and then - Google is a bit more capable
and conversational now especially
compared to Siri in the past so when I
say capable I mean you know both
assistants can make a call send a
message send a tweet turn on and off
Wi-Fi Bluetooth stuff like that but
Google because of this AI learning has
gotten to the point where can say show
me pictures of a cat that I took at my
house last week and it will show you
that it kind of knows a lot about you
and I'm it's just more general
conversational flow with Google
assistant so you can ask about previous
answers and clarify stuff just feels
more like a talking to another person
and that actually used to be series
strength compared to Google now where
Google didn't really have any jokes or
any funny answers to questions and don't
get me wrong serious still does that but
now it feels like here the thing is the
way I judge these voice assistants is
how much like a robot you have to talk
to it to get it to understand you and I
think Google has passed Siri in that
department you don't have to ask the
same question three different ways to
get your answer you can just ask about a
previous question you get the idea I
think that's where it's passed so they
have it the 2016 version of this
comparison kind of interesting to see it
now versus the way it was in 2012 and
I'll be interested to see the way it
looks in 2020 but let me know which one
you guys are more of a fan of a Siri
person or a Google assistant person let
me know in the comments section that's
pretty much been it thanks for watching
I'll talk to you guys the next one peace
[Music]
games Showtime
okay okay I'm gonna psych myself up now
stay calm sorry not you I'm talking to
myself